Would you consider a more official
consultancy role with Andrew Scheer's
Conservative Party?
Uh,
it's very difficult to say what I would
consider.
It isn't obvious to me that Andrew
Scheer would particularly like to have
me as no official consultant time kind
of a,
what might you describe a controversial?
Yes,
that's the word right now.
And so,
you know,
it's funny though because I was making
this new video today,
which I alluded to earlier,
using good old,
what's this character here?
A Hitler,
the Hitler,
the spokes frog.
And uh,
I,
I went back and looked at my comments on
bill [inaudible] last year,
which,
which were the comments that originally
got me in hot water and had me accused
of all the things I've been accused of
Transphobia,
bigotry,
racism.
Um,
what else?
Oh,
you fascism being on the far right.
And then finally,
and to top it all off,
Hitler himself.
And one of the things that I realized
was that,
that I was really calm during that
video.
You couldn't have really.
I couldn't have offered a more mild
mannered criticism,
a bill [inaudible].
And it's pretty funny because,
you know,
I'm this scandal that engulfed Wilford
Laurey a this week is the worst scandal
that I remember involving a university
in,
in my memory,
going back to the 19 seventies.
And what happened at Laurie was exactly
what I predicted would happen except it
was actually worse because they did
accuse Lynsay of breaking the law spill,
see 16 specifically.
And if contravening the Ontario Human
Rights Code,
which I,
you know,
for all I know she might've done.
So we're,
we're at this situation where a Ta
showing a video of someone discussing
pronouns and candidate can now be termed
a hate crime and illegal provincially
and federally.
And like all the usual suspects have
come out of there.
Their caves,
let's say.
I'm like Brenda Cossman,
the lawyer I debated last year and said,
well,
it's a real stretch to assume that what
Lindsay Shepherd did was,
was,
you know,
sufficiently reprehensible to actually
constitute a violation of the Ontario
Human Rights Commission guidelines,
policies,
uh,
hits a stretch.
So I guess we're supposed to feel good
about that.
But,
um,
I'm probably a little bit too hot right
now to serve in any official consultant
role.
Uh,
that doesn't mean that I wouldn't be
happy to speak to,
you know,
political figures who might be
interested in speaking with me because,
you know,
I generally speak to people who asked me
to speak to them.
So,
um,
as reprehensible as that might be.